alexandre grignon n'aura pas raté le
rendez vous le jeune cadet de l'us
créteil remporte l'élimination l'une des
épreuves de l'omnium
c'est la quatrième fois qu'ils
participent au grand prix de vélizy le
niveau il évolue de plus en plus chaque
année donc c'est bien pour pouvoir
performer et s'améliorer de plus en plus
donc c'est pas un truc qui me dérange
c'est pas gagné
on apprend une matinée réservée aux
minimes cadets et cadettes venus de neuf
comités régionaux différents et des
yvelinois avec des objectifs plein la
tête
il faut que je réussisse à les courses à
des coupes d'hiver pour partir en coupe
de france essayait de me démarquer sur
les coupes de france pour faire accepter
la france et ses bancs de l'église
pour ce sixième grand prix 170 coureurs
ont fait le déplacement une journée de
compétition de la catégorie minimes aux
seniors 3 épreuves différentes étaient
proposés vitesse keirin et omnium
à chaque fois on découvre de jeunes
talents et aujourd'hui les jeunes qui
sont en équipe de france sont tous
passés par le grand prix de vélizy pour
avoir une élite en france il faut donner
envie aux jeunes
et là c'est une occasion formidable
parce que nous sommes dans le vélodrome
nationale qui sera le théâtre des jeux
olympiques de 2024 et il faut faire
rêver les jeunes et courir au vélodrome
nationale
là ça fait partie du rêve ce grand prix
était la première manche de la coupe
d'hiver la prochaine se tient le premier
des cent - toujours au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines